on vendra merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france à l'heure on attend près de
trente mille manifestants paris selon
vous pourquoi le mouvement de
contestation contre le passé ni terre ne
faiblit pas
la question qui est posée n'est pas une
question de santé principalement c'est
une question de liberté et d'obéissance
c'est à dire que le pass sanitaire n'est
pas quelque chose qui va empêcher de
vivre les gens qui ne l'ont pas il va
leur empêcher d'accéder à des loisirs il
va leur empêché de pouvoir faire leur
travail dans certains cas ou créer des
conditions défavorables par exemple vous
pouvez aller à lyon en deux heures en
tgv avec un pass sanitaire en 5 heures
en ter sans pass sanitaires c'est cette
idée qui affronte l'égalité qui est au
coeur des représentations que les
français se font de la république qui
est la base de feu refus si vous prenez
la suède où il n'y a pas eu de
confinement où il n'y a pas eu de
masques en extérieur où il n'y a pas de
dispositif de type passe sanitaires
les résultats sont un peu meilleurs que
la france sur le vide ils sont
extrêmement supérieur sur les
dépressions les suicides et toutes
sortes de choses que l'on voit ici en
quantité et la suède est massivement
vacciner parce que le gouvernement a
fait un travail d'explication si on
prend l'espagne le conseil
constitutionnel a cassé la loi sur le
pass sanitaires le gouvernement a été
contraint à une politique d'explication
qui a pris la population à témoin de la
situation scientifiques médicales
sociales le résultat c'est que l'espagne
est avec le portugal le pays le plus
vaccinée en europe alors que la france
n'arrive pas à être à ce même niveau
parce que des politiques constamment
changeante et la mise en examen de
madame busin est un élément de plus de
la décrédibilisation ont conduit à ce
que le gouvernement n'apparaît pas comme
crédibles par les multiples revirements
qu'il a eu sur les multiples sujets le
masque ne sert à rien le masque est
obligatoire c'est 135 aussi vous ne
l'avez pas les tests ce n'est pas très
utile les tests sont indispensables on
va en faire partout et toujours ces
changements ont profondément désarçonné
une population qui a été par ailleurs
soumise à un feu médiatique chantant
chaque heure le nombre de morts comme un
score de football qui a fini par sidéré
la population donc le résultat c'est un
cocktail explosif qui fait que 200
manifestations ont lieu depuis
maintenant deux mois chaque samedi
les médias dominants donne le chiffre
fourni le vendredi par le ministère de
l'intérieur pour les manifestations du
samedi ça n'est donc pas très éclairant
sur le vrai nombre de gens qui
participent mais on peut penser que ce
ne sont pas les mêmes gens qui étaient
en juillet à toulon en août à toulon en
septembre à toulon et il en est de même
pour un très grand nombre de villes du
pays dont la population change
en cette période de vacances notamment
les villes côtières et on voit que la
participation globale à ces
manifestations a été fort nombreuses
même si elle recouvre des protestations
qui sont très différentes il y a des
gens qui sont hostiles aux vaccins qui
sont très minoritaires mais ils sont là
ils se manifestent et puis il y a des
gens qui aussi notent que le dispositif
dit du pass sanitaire passe par deux
fûts toutes les garanties qu'offre aux
salariés le code du travail ainsi
l'employeur va les mettre à pied sans
salaire sans qu'ils aient droit à
aucun dispositif de chômage ni partiel
ni total donc c'est un dispositif qui
permet d' affamer des salariés ce que
toute la loi depuis 1936 soir 1905 est
fait pour empêcher donc on voit bien
qu'il y a dans ce dispositif du pass
sanitaire qui est construit de manière
très contraire à l'esprit français
quelque chose qui est de nature
explosive monsieur casanova on le sait
dans ces manifestations il y a des gens
vaccinés mais qui sont contre le pass
sanitaires car il estime que finalement
le gouvernant est passée voilà qu'on 30
ans pour pousser les français à se faire
vacciner
vous parliez de la communication du
gouvernement français qui a été
discrédité s qui ne en échec clairement
de communication de la part du
gouvernement français depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire
on peut difficilement imaginer un échec
plus flamboyant vous vous souvenez de la
porte parole du gouvernement disant
qu'elle savait pas mettre un masque vous
vous souvenez de toutes ces choses
multiples qui ont été annoncées et
dictée comme des vérités absolues puis
renversé quelques temps plus tard donc
il y a un déficit de crédibilité qui est
du à
deux choses premièrement une manière de
dire tout et son contraire agnès buzyn a
déclaré après
première phase où il y avait eu trois
malades que maintenant c'était terminé
le coronavirus en france s'est terminée
la france était totalement à l'abri
un certain nombre de responsables ont
indiqué que la france était entièrement
prêtes s'ils arrivaient une épidémie
elle avait tout ce qui était nécessaire
dans le domaine matériel technique on a
vu par la suite que c'était
rigoureusement faux donc le fait de dire
des contrevérités en permanence à
discréditer un gouvernement même
lorsqu'il disait des choses rationnelles
raisonnable et que la population aurait
dû suivre à la lettre parce que cette
fois ci c'était la bonne idée comment
distinguer cela du reste et puis alors
depuis le 12 juillet nous avons la prise
du pouvoir par le jeune emmanuel macron
il n'y a plus personne d'autre il n'y a
plus que lui qui décide tout est mis en
scène de telle façon à faire apparaître
que il est le seul à juger le seul à
décider de temps en temps simplement
quelques juges casse des décisions comme
par exemple sur les centres commerciaux
mais il apparaît donc que c'est qu'une
seule personne qui décide et ça ça
n'inspire pas la confiance d'abord parce
que cette personne est contestée comme
vous le savez comme il le sait lui même
et d'autres pas parce que on est plus
intelligent à plusieurs et que le
premier ministre qui selon l'article 20
de la constitution
détermine et conduit la politique du
pays est maintenant remise et au rôle de
monsieur déconfinement monsieur
couvre-feu monsieurr confinement
monsieur passe sanitaire mais pas
beaucoup plus donc on voit bien là que
on a tous les éléments pour rendre
conflictuelle des choses qui ne
devraient pas l'être là encore prenons
l'exemple du portugal de l'espagne de la
suède ça se passe très différemment avec
des gouvernements qui pourtant ont eu
les mêmes conseillers amérique mckinsey
mais qui n'ont pas suivi à la lettre ses
conseils parce que quelques instances
dans leur pays leur ont dit de ne pas le
faire pour la suède ils n'ont pas suivi
du tout celle casanova merci à vous
d'avoir est en direct sur arte france je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
stratégie et communication